look Appa we made it the Christmas tree
temple Wow yeah see all the cool
decorations they got there's the Pepe
LePew division and yeah there's the the
Garfield part of the temple I bet that
part's awesome and Oh best part the
present part oh my God look at that
Apple look at that awesome so cool okay
so this is Appa as you all well know and
what's he doing in my Christmas video
well I was thinking to myself well what
do I do for this Christmas video for
some reason I kept coming back to this
guy and the reason I did is because I
thought about it and I realized that the
reason that I love this guy so much is
because he actually came from a fan a
fan who watched my work and said that I
apparently really helped get through
some really tough times you know
everybody goes through tough times and
I'm thinking my soul I'm just making an
ass of myself you know I'm just doing
comedy and funny little things like that
and I've been getting more and more of
these letters and and these emails and
stuff and I I didn't see them coming I
really didn't expect it and I I'm not
saying this to be like your attire
mazing art I'm saving the world that
that's not at all you can hate my work
it's totally hate it I don't care but
what I'm trying to get at with it is
that the reason I did it wasn't for that
reason and leaves intentionally it was
just spread a little cheer I have a
little fun you know just make some
laughs and I'm learning more and more
with the more these emails and letters I
get that can really go a long way and I
didn't see that coming I didn't expect
that and every single time you know
people say spread the holiday cheer or
spread goodness and stuff like that as I
yeah whatever commercialism and you know
singing some Christmas carols isn't
gonna make the world any better but you
know it kind of does and I didn't know
how and I didn't know why but now I kind
of do sometimes just that little bit of
effort because like I said Christmas is
about effort just that little bit
it can go a long way maybe someone's
just feeling miserable and had the
hardest time and just doing something
nice I give them a compliment or any of
that stuff can really really make him
feel better and we always say so many
things can get us angry so many things
can bring us down just the smallest
things can really piss us off well you
know what the smallest things can also
make you feel better the little
surprises the things you didn't see
coming just the little smiles on a
person you didn't think would smile at
whatever reason or whatever thing so I'm
really thankful for Alpha here I'm
really thankful to that fan and I'm
thankful to all the fans who say that
stuff even though I feel bad when I
can't reply cuz it's like that I do have
so much to do but just know I am so
thankful for those emails and I do save
them too because that's the stuff that
gives me joy that's the stuff that
really makes me feel good as when people
talk about how much I've helped just
doing something as silly as this so I
guess I'm saying don't underestimate the
stupid little stuff that is cheerful but
you think doesn't matter it does it
really does matter and if you don't know
that now you'll find out later it's just
a really cool thing and I think you know
that's Christmas man that's that's just
a good feeling it's something so small
can have such a huge big impact and
that's one of the things I love about
because Christmas isn't physical it's
not something you can grab it's just
something you feel and you experience
and you feel it every year we try our
best to feel it all year round and of
course that doesn't work but we still
try and that again that effort goes a
long long way so from all of us at
channel awesome we want which you the
happiest of Christmases have a wonderful
wonderful holiday right up
you